what you know it's like everything else
in this country it does particular
moment which is we've not really caught
up to change reality technologically and
socially and economically we've not
really dealt with change very well the
curriculum we're teaching in schools is
the same curriculum we were teaching 40
years ago by and large and and but the
world is nothing like it was four years
ago and you could say this in a whole
vast arena of things in the country so
you know media literacy is not saw the
consumers fault we don't teach it we
don't we don't we don't acknowledge that
media as a concept has grown so complex
and so diversified that you actually
need to explain it to people if you're
going to teach civics in you know grade
school then you then part of civics is
you ought to be teaching media you have
to explain people have to learn what to
expect you're not born knowing the the
differences in media how it operates and
and and what your expectation should be
event maybe instead of teaching the
Revolutionary War six times we could
teach the Revolutionary War three times
and include you know some media literacy
in the curriculum so I you know I don't
think it's a consumers fault it's just
that we don't we don't place any value
on actually orienting people toward a
really confusing media environment and
they get angry because their
expectations are off